unity is imperative
in america polarization in some ways is
more common than us coming together we
didn't just become divided
we let hate into our hearts you want to
know why trump is durable in the
republican imagination the republican
establishment is still making nice and
doing shoulder massages with the people
who are using unity as a club and
trump's like i'm just not going to play
that game
joe biden is praising george w bush for
the unity speech but he's really
praising him because he believes that
george w bush is attacking
people purportedly of the right but
never anybody
on the left right this is what unity
means to people
of joe biden's ilk
unity means we are right and you are
wrong and you shut up and if you
disagree
there's no unity that's what joe biden
means and i don't take seriously that
joe biden is particularly upset about
january 6th because january 6 is worse
in kind than the riots we saw that
wrecked the cities across the summer and
have led to a radically exacerbated
murder rate in every major city in
america i just don't believe that that
he he even believes that
i think that he believes that people who
agree with his agenda are basically good
and people who disagree with his agenda
are basically bad
that is not a unifying perspective
kamala harris is doing the same thing
right you're granting this is why i'm
very frustrated with with george w
bush's speech not because of the
critique of one sex but because of the
inability to
to know and understand
that radicalism on all sides of all
aisles is a major major problem when you
only critique one side of the aisle and
then you say that unity is in the offing
you are incorrect
all you're doing is granting favor to
people who have actively promoted the
disunity
if you're not willing to condemn all of
the bad things you're only willing to
condemn some of the bad things you're
fomenting others of the bad things the
left knows this which is why they were
using bush's speech over the weekend
here's kamala harris doing the same
thing calling for unity this is
absolutely galling stuff coming from
kamala harris
i mean it's
here she is calling for unity
unity is imperative
in america
it is essential to our shared prosperity
to our national security
and to our standing in the world
and by unity i don't mean uniformity
we had differences of opinion in 2001
as we do
in 2021
and i believe that in america
our diversity is our strength
she's a liar when she says that she
doesn't believe that unity is uniformity
no she 100 does
she does not believe in diversity of
opinion in any serious way
you can look at her legislative record
on this it is pretty clear
this is not a person who deeply cares
about diversity of opinion is a person
who's part of an administration that is
attacking other americans for adversity
of opinion yet the same thing from media
got jim acosta doing the same thing what
happened to our unity what happened
we didn't just become divided
we let hate into our hearts
for each other
there was an expression used after nine
eleven
all gave some some gave all
we don't really do that anymore
some of us don't want to give anything
at all
we live in separate worlds now
we don't agree on the same facts anymore
we can't even agree on wearing masks or
getting vaccinated to end this pandemic
why isn't there unity because of you
people who won't mask after being
vaccinated yeah i wonder why there's not
unity george w bush calls for unity and
in the process of calling for unity he
basically name checks the 1 6 rioters
but nothing else right that is where
he's putting his his sole focus which is
inherently unifying because it turns out
that there are a lot of
threads in the fabric of america that
are being torn asunder many of them by
the leadership of the united states
which george w bush has studiously
ignored as long as it is coming from the
left since 2008. and this is coming from
somebody who voted for george w i wasn't
old enough to vote in 2000 i voted for
george w bush in 2004 and supported much
of his agenda
it is extremely frustrating and it's
extremely frustrating to watch people
who ripped him and wrecked his
presidency now use george w bush and his
statements as a tool to wield on behalf
of an inherently ununifying agenda
disunifying agenda you got kamala harris
saying that she also believes in unity
and jim acosta's saying he believes in
unity no you don't you're liars
you absolutely do not i know you don't
because last summer kamal harris was
backing rioters last summer kamala
harris was tweeting out about how we
could actually bail out rioters in
minneapolis
you remember her famous tweet on this
her infamous tweet on this
in which she tweeted out if you're able
to chip in now to the minnesota freedom
fund to help post bail for those
protesting on the ground in minnesota
the people in jail were not protesters
they were rioters but don't worry she's
not for uniformity she's only for unity
you know joe biden is like ah it was a
great speech by by you know it's time
for us to come together it's time for
last week he was labeling the
unvaccinated the worst among us it never
mind if they're by the way no exceptions
for natural immunity no exceptions for
other health conditions if you're
unvaccinated you're a bad person
according to joe biden and he's going to
lecture you about it but he's for unity
you see
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free
safe and convenient
the vaccine is fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
that's that's captain unity over there
right the man who's bringing us all
together the person with whom george w
bush is meeting across the table to talk
about unity you have the media jim
acosta one of the most divisive media
figures of the last several years out
there talking about how we can't even
have unity why can't we have unity like
we had in 9 11. we can't even have unity
about masking right because there are
serious questions to be asked about the
necessity of masking in a time when
every american adult has the ability to
go get vaccinated right there are
serious data questions to be asked about
the efficacy of particular types of
masks and their studies that demonstrate
the cloth masks against the delta
variant are not particularly effective
for example but according to jim acosta
if you don't do what he wants you to do
you are threatening unity and this is
the the shtick of the left and george
shelley bush played right into it the
stick of the left is
that unity is offered by monopoly and if
you are a person who exists outside of
the monopoly then you have now created
two poles which means polarization
polarization is a simple result
according to the left of your failure to
agree with them
right the same media who are decrying
lack of unity on 9 11 spent most of 9 11
trying to jabber about how coveted was
like 9 11. copenhagen is not like 9 11.
i mean it's certainly not it's not like
9 11 in the sense that you guys won't
even blame the people who are
responsible namely the chinese
government but not only that code is not
like 911 because it's hit everywhere
it's a global pandemic and yet the left
kept saying over and over that it was
like 911. the implication being that
people who refuse to do what we want are
like the terrorists that is the
implication
msnbc chuck todd over the weekend
compared 911 to covet this is not a
comparison
i guess the best way to look at the two
battles that that the country engaged in
we had an outside invader in al qaeda
and so we were able to
unite we had a common enemy with coven
this invisible enemy were not able to do
it and you know willie thinking about
this all week when you actually
sadly you look at the arc of uh of
american
history
polarization in some ways is more common
than us coming together
i mean and then you get from nicole
wallace that it's like 9 11 every couple
of days covered no it is not it is like
a health problem that is killing a lot
of people
by the way health problems which we have
a solution namely go get yourself
vaccinated and if you don't want to then
you bear the consequences of that that's
not like 9 11 in any way shape or form
that's like if on 9 11 you had the
option to leave the building before
okay that is not the same thing at all
and also it's as though the attackers on
9 11
had no actual will or agenda because
viruses don't but here's nicole wallace
making that absurd comparison again the
implication being that the people who
refuse to go along with the agenda here
are the ones who are leading to disunity
i think there are so many parallels to
how much more difficult it is to do any
of the things that anyone who has spoken
today has done to call the country to a
higher purpose
you've got politicians and prominent
folks in in the media um
outraged by steps that a president not
too many presidents after the one we
heard from today would try to save his
country from an unthinkable death toll i
mean as many people die every two days
has died on september 11th in this
country who don't have to
die and yet there's no unity no unity no
unity why isn't there unity
we all know why there's no unity and
it's because the basic principles that
you see unite the united states have
gone the way of the roto bird they were
barely there even when bush was
president in fact many of them crumbled
while bush was president
and this is what's so frustrating i
think to so many people on the right
watching george w bush's speech and
looking at many and the republican
establishment who seem
to feel the same way as george w bush
that unity is just around the corner if
only i condemn this specific set of
people but not broadly speaking all
people who commit these sorts of sins
like that
it's playing right into the hands of
people who actively use uni
unity as a as a guise
for
a uniformity
yeah and and again i i do find it
calling that george w bush apparently
only emerges to critique the the
perspectives of people he purports to
see as on the right right like that that
that is it's particularly galling to me
especially when you have the president
of the united states who just destroyed
george w bush's legacy in afghanistan
let's be frank about this george w bush
went into afghanistan with uniformity of
purpose there was uniformity one member
of congress voted against it
okay everyone wanted to go into
afghanistan
even barack obama in 2008 was calling it
the good war in 2008.
and joe biden decided to pull out and
hand the country directly back to the
taliban and then on the 20th anniversary
of 9 11 he was talking about why he was
right to do so and talking about and
setting up these false binaries where i
mean it's unbelievable he's
in places like shanksville he's meeting
with he's meeting with first responders
and he's talking about how you know we
really have to be circumspect in how we
fight al qaeda if you had told anybody
that we were going to spend
300 million bucks a day for 20 years to
try to unite the country
after
we got bin laden
al-qaeda was wiped out there
can i kind of come back yeah but guess
what it's already back other places
what's the strategy every place where al
qaeda is we're going to invade and have
troops staying
come on
no the strategy is everywhere al-qaeda
is we're going to go in and we are going
to kill them i mean i thought that was
literally the point of the war on terror
the entire point of it that any place
they were they were using as a base to
threaten the united states we were going
to go and kill them that was the basic
idea of the war on terror
okay so all of this leads to trump
because trump isn't having this right
you want to know why trump is durable in
the republican imagination the reason
trump is durable in the republican
imagination is because trump is not
having any of this bullcrap
my way or the highway unity
he's not going to sit around and pretend
that joe biden is a unifying figure he's
not going to make patty cake with the
obamas who are highly polarizing figures
in american political life
he is not going to sit around and
pretend that joe biden is some sort of
figure figure of great magnanimity who
simply wants us all to come together
and so well normally it is sort of
considered uncouth on 9 11 to talk about
the failures of a of an administration
currently in power it becomes a lot less
uncouth when you have an entire
administration that has directed itself
to destroying the purpose of the
american response to 911 so when trump
just doesn't operate inside the same
sphere as the republican establishment
the republican establishment is still
making nice and doing shoulder massages
with the people who are using unity as a
club and trump's like i'm just not going
to play that game
you wonder why he's popular at the
republican base still that is the reason
he is popular at the republican base
still now he's not the only one who can
do this there are other people on the
right who are doing this as well
you all know why ron desantis in florida
is popular at the republican base it's
because he does this with regard to
coveted in the media all the time but
the reason that trump is popular with
the republican base is he is not going
to pretend that he and joe biden are on
the same page when it comes to things
like afghanistan like it is somewhat mad
again it is maddening to me that joe
biden who spent years backing the
afghanistan campaign under george w bush
but then simultaneously undermined bush
at every available turn 20 years later
destroys what's going on in afghanistan
by the way everything going on with
covid everything going on with the
budget it is all an attempt to distract
from his failure in afghanistan that is
what this is it's why he's trying to ram
it through
and trump wasn't having any of that so
his presidential message oh it's not
presidential why couldn't he be
presidential like bush
maybe because he's being realistic
unlike bush here was trump yesterday
it is also a sad time for the way our
war on those that did such harm to our
country ended last week
the loss of 13 great warriors and the
many more who were wounded
should never have happened the leader of
our country was made to look like a fool
and that could never be allowed to
happen
it was caused by bad planning incredible
weakness and leaders who truly didn't
understand what was happening this is
the 20th year of this war
and should have been a year of victory
and honor and strength
instead joe biden and his inept
administration surrendered in defeat
okay not only is he not wrong he is
correct about what time it is as they
say he is correct that we don't live in
a world where unity of purpose is a
thing and anybody on the left or on the
right who tells you the unity of purpose
in america is still a thing
is missing the game they are missing the
game that is being played
okay in afghanistan right now the
taliban started flying their flag over
the presidential palace in kabul on the
day of the 20th anniversary of 9 11. the
white banner with the shahada that's the
testimony written across it was raised
at an 11am ceremony on saturday to mark
the beginning of the work for the
taliban's caretaker government
the taliban did not issue a formal
statement on the anniversary of the al
qaeda terrorist attacks that pro that
polluted them being driven from power 20
years earlier but the image of the flag
was a stunning reminder of course
meanwhile
the
biden administration it now turns out on
their way out of afghanistan remember
they had this quote unquote successful
drone attack to go after the isis
members who
perpetrated that terror attack that
killed 13 americans well it turns out in
all likelihood according to the new york
times they did in fact kill an afghan
translator and members of his family
but they had no idea who they were
hitting
is that unity
the taliban are going around literally
beating women in the streets
there's video of it emerging
is that unity women are now in hiding
all over afghanistan and we're supposed
to pretend that unity is just it's just
under the surface if only we could get
at it if only and we're supposed to
pretend that we don't know the reasons
for the disunity we know the reasons for
the disunity
don't don't gaslight the american people
by telling them that that we are all in
favor of unity you are not
you are not the folks on the left are on
the hard left and in the bind
administration are not in favor of unity
they don't want to explain what they are
doing politically they don't want to
explain why their policies are right
they don't want to brook dissent
they want to use the powers of the
federal government to ram through
anything that they can without regard
for the constitutional process they want
to do it in top-down fashion
they want to completely rewrite the
american national bargain
and they want to castigate all of their
opponents as inherently polarizing for
things like
really you're telling me i need to mask
up my five-year-old
the answer there is no
which is why again
you want trump you're gonna get more of
him is how you're gonna get more trump
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed